can you just give us the latest figures
on how
how widespread this india variant is in
the united kingdom
well in total we've seen just over 1300
cases of this
indian variant it is becoming the
dominant strain in some parts of the
country for instance in
bolton and in blackburn
and it's there in smaller numbers much
lower numbers
in other parts of the country one of the
advantages we now have compared to
uh compared to the past compared to
december when we saw the
the kent variant uh coming up is that we
have the vaccination program as you
mentioned but we also have this
incredible testing and surveillance
system so we can see these cases even
though the numbers are really
quite small at the moment which means
that we're able to
to take this cautious step forward
tomorrow
and continue on the road map whilst
monitoring this very very carefully and
taking specific action
in the areas where we can see the the
the prevalence of this of this new
variant like bolton
talking about the surveillance system so
we can really monitor
how this new variant moves and so what
does the data
show us we're told we're told on friday
that it's likely to be more
transmissible
but the vaccines do seem to be working
against it is that still the case
yes so there is new very early data
out from oxford university and i would
say i would
stress that this is from the labs it's
not clinical data
and it is very early but it does give us
a degree of confidence that the vaccines
work
against this indium variant but it is
clearly more transmissible
and has been spreading fast in in
in the groups where there's a um where
there's a cluster
and and that means that we can stay on
course with our strategy
of using the vaccine to deal with this
pandemic
and of opening up carefully and
cautiously
but we do need to be really very
vigilant
to the spread of the disease and you
know the metaphor the prime minister
uses the right one we're in a race
between the vaccination program and the
virus
and this new variant has given the virus
some extra legs in that race
but the vaccine will still we have a
high degree of confidence that the
vaccine
will overcome and and so the main
message i've got for everybody this
morning
is get vaccinated if you're in one of
the eligible groups
come forward and get a jab in bolton
where we've seen a number of people
in hospital with this new indian variant
the vast majority of them have been
eligible for a jab but not taken the jab
so if you're eligible for the jab if
you're over the age of 38
please come forward because we know that
the jab protects you and we know that
with a high degree of confidence that
the jab will have
an effect against this new variant too
what i think i guess i'm struggling to
understand what some others might under
struggle to understand
is you say there's a high confidence
that the vaccines work
against the variant and i accept your
point that the vast majority of people
in the hot spots in hospital those who
are unvaccinated
but at the same time more than 56
million vaccine doses have been given
out
you know the vast majority of people
over the age of
50 people in the most vulnerable groups
have had at least one dose
why should we be talking about even june
being blown off
course um if we know that the vaccines
work
and so many people have been vaccinated
like who is going to be in in the
hospitals
well the answer is that because this
variant can spread
even faster than the than the kent
variant that we saw
and we saw what happened with that in
december it means that
if it gets out of hand we'll have a very
very large number of cases
and so even with the protection that the
vaccine gives you
that is the vaccine protection is very
high but it is not absolute you know 97
protection against dying from covert is
fantastic
but it isn't a hundred and so we do need
to make
sure that we don't get that total um
that explosion in cases so we need to be
cautious
we need to be careful we need to be
vigilant and we've said at
each step we will look at the four tests
that we have we assessed those
last week for the tests for the move
that we're making
as a country tomorrow and our assessment
was all for our met
the fourth of those four tests is
whether a new variant knocks us off
course
and we will we'll of course be assessing
that over the weeks to come and we'll
make a final decision
for the step four uh which is the
biggest step on the roadmap we'll make
that final decision
on the 14th of june um so
we always said we want this to be
cautious
we really want it to be irreversible you
know new variants are one of the biggest
risks
to this uh to this opening
because of the speed of transmission of
this one it can it can
you know it can really spread like
wildfire amongst the unvaccinated groups
hence we need to get as many people
vaccinated as possible
particularly in those who are most
vulnerable to ending up in hospital
listening to what you're saying there
you know that the spread is clearly
something that we're
still very worried about and even though
the vaccines work
they may not work for everybody and
tomorrow yes it's because of the law of
law it's because of a law of large
numbers you know even though
the vaccine gives you that huge amount
of protection
um it it is if you get a very large
number of cases
some people are not in terms of
hospitalization so some people who've
been vaccinated frankly
could still end up in hospital and could
still die
well a very small proportion that's true
under
uh under the existing variance as well
you know it's the flip side of saying 97
protection against death is that does
still leave that three percent chance
that's one of the reasons why
in over the long term we talk about
where we want to get to with this
disease as managing it like
flu you know people get vaccinated for
flu every year as well
and um it's all about getting the risks
down to a to a manageable level
and making sure that we don't see a big
increase
like we saw with the kent variant but
the difference between now and
december is both we've got the vaccine
which is great
and protects people from hospitalization
but also we have this
amazing testing and surveillance system
so we can send in the
the surge testing into places like
bolton and blackburn 35 000 people were
trying to reach over this weekend
even despite that sage are still very
worried
about this reopening that is happening
uh tomorrow indoor socializing
up to six people pubs restaurants homes
i mean exactly the kind of conditions of
course
that covert 19 likes inside and just
looking at the latest minutes so
sage is saying that if this variant is
40 to 50 more transmissible than the
kent varian that's what chris woody
suggested is very possible
then it's likely that tomorrow's changes
would lead to a substantial resurgence
of hospitalizations
similar to or larger than previous peaks
if that is the case why are we
proceeding with the reopening tomorrow
well the most important word in that
sentence and obviously i
i not only have seen those minutes but
i've also talked to the
scientists uh who are following uh this
with us and and advising on it the most
important
word in that sentence is if and we don't
know yet
the increase in transmissibility what we
do know is
that it's highly that it's very possible
that it is 50
and surely people would understand that
why don't we wait until we do know how
transmissible it is even if it's a
matter of couple weeks the thing is
though
the thing is though sophie and i know
that you get this it's
often quite hard to communicate
epidemiology is all
about the balance of risks and there are
no
absolutes as our just our discussion
just now about the protection you get
from the vaccine
demonstrates if the transmissibility is
as high as that then we will have a
problem
and we've been totally frank with people
and the prime minister i thought was
very
very strong on friday when he described
the risks that we face from this new
variant but
it may be that the transmissibility the
increase in transmissibility
is much lower and in that case
there will be almost no impact on our on
our roadmap and on the future a number
of cases
and we just don't yet know so that's why
it's appropriate
to continue down the road map but people
need to be
cautious and careful and we're anyway
moving the
the balance more towards people taking
personal responsibility
and and trying to get away from some of
the
more intrusive rules that we've had to
have in place
and but of course we also are absolutely
clear that we'll do what it takes to
keep the public
safe as we learn more about this
about this particular variant and about
the virus overall
so you said that if transmissibility is
that high then there will be a problem
does that mean that
even though i know that the prime
minister has said that the changes
uh they want to be cautious but
irreversible
may you have to roll back on some of the
changes that are happening tomorrow
well i very much hope not and our
goal our our goal remains as i said at
the start
our goal remains our strategy remains to
take a cautious and irreversible
approach uh to ensure that we're always
looking at the data always all the way
through
and crucially to use the vaccine
to get us out of this pandemic if you're
looking at the data
if you're following the data not the
dates it would be correct to assume that
the changes happening tomorrow
may have to be reversed if the data says
so
well that's that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying that actually the
uh the news and the data that we have
the information we have about the
variant
uh thus far uh tells us actually that
our strategy remains on track
it's just that in this race between the
vaccine and the variant
the variant has got a has got some more
legs i mean that's the
that is the that makes it more
challenging
but it but the overall strategy
of getting us out of this by vaccinating
uh is on track and
and it's only on track and i just really
want to stress this for all of your
viewers
it's only on track because of the very
very high uptake rates of the
of the vaccine and what's happening in
bolton right now
demonstrates why it's so important for
everybody
to get vaccinated when the call comes
because the people who are ending up
in hospital in bolton with this new
variant are largely people who are
eligible for the vaccine but haven't
taken the vaccine
so if you're eligible if you're 38 years
old or older
you haven't yet had your jab please come
forward now
because that is what is going to help
you but it's going to help the whole
country to get out of this pandemic
the prime minister has said that there
could be serious disruption to
stage four of the roadmap that of course
the changes planned for
june when the end of this kind of social
restrictions was planned
how likely do you think that disruption
is i know it's difficult to say exactly
yeah it's it's the question everybody's
asking
and and the answer is it's too early to
tell what i can do is give you a
timeline
which is that we're going to monitor all
of this data
there's new data coming in every single
day
and then we're going to take and
announce a decision
on the 14th of june um as always through
this
pandemic we'll be as tran transparent as
we possibly can be with the data
you know you can follow it all on
coronavirus.gov uk
um and we will obviously keep answering
questions about our best judgment about
that uh
decision and then we'll take it on the
uh
on the 14th of june so i i i'm really
sorry that i can't answer that question
it's because it's too early to say and
that demonstrates this
you know this uh this this dictum that
we have which is that we follow the data
not the dates
um and uh uh we'd love to take that step
if it's safe to do so but um
we will we'll keep monitoring and make
sure that we keep people safe
understood um would any changes happen
nationally or could we see a system
where
areas of the country with higher
incidences of
paces hospitalizations whichever measure
have
different restrictions to elsewhere
yeah well we don't rule that out the
approach that we're taking in bolton
and in blackburn is to absolutely
pile in testing and vaccinations
to try to get on top of this you know
when we had an outbreak of the south
african variant
in south london last month we put
in a huge amount hundreds of thousands
of tests in surge testing people came
forward in their droves
uh across southwark and lambeth and
wandsworth
and um we got that under control that
was
the testing tracing system working very
effectively
to clamp down on an outbreak now we're
taking the same approach
in bolton and in blackburn
we've put in a huge amount of testing
we've we've reinforced that with army
personnel as well
and we're expanding the the vaccination
program
especially for those second jobs which
are the best protection about against
ending up in hospital so at the moment
we're taking the
approach that worked in south london
which is this uh
massive surge testing um but of course
we don't rule out further action
and you know given though that bolton
has been in some kind of a lockdown for
a year uh you know i i'm it's not a step
we'd want to take
but of course of course we might have to
take it and we will if it's necessary to
uh to protect people now i want to talk
to you about
borders because there's a lot of people
who are looking at the situation
and thinking this could have been
prevented this could have been prevented
if the government had acted
more quickly so the indian variant first
detected in the uk
in the week ending the 29th of march on
the 2nd of april it was announced that
pakistan and bangladesh were going on
the red list
india wasn't even though there were much
higher
case numbers in india and it wasn't
added to the red list until the 19th of
april
didn't actually implemented being on the
red list until the 23rd
of april these this really matters
doesn't it
it was too slow
no i i mean i've seen this argument be
made in some places and it's
frankly completely wrong and it
misrepresents
how these uh the the evidence on which
you can take these decisions
so you know this variant was notified as
a variant under investigation
uh after we'd already put india on the
red list
the decision to put india on the red
list was taken because of the high
positivity rate of people coming from
india and looking at the
epi curve in india when we put pakistan
on the red list at the start of april
that's because the proportion of
positive
people testing positive coming in from
pakistan was
three times higher the proportion coming
from india
and and it was only after we put india
on the red list that this variant
became went under investigation and then
later earlier this month that it became
a variant of concern
about new variants should it the case
numbers are also
something that surely should be looked
at if you just look at the data from the
16th of april for example
there are 137 daily new cases in india
per million people in pakistan that
number was 22 in bangladesh it was 33.
and between late march and the 26th of
april
122 people arriving from mumbai and
delhi
had the indian variant they're just the
people that we know about
surely it was too slow
uh no so the first thing is we have some
of the strongest border measures
in the world and all of those people
they didn't went through a testing
regime
all of those people needed to go through
a testing regime and a
an isolation regime but the second point
is that what matters is the positivity
of people coming to this country so you
can't actually just compare those
uh those test positivity figures as you
did because it depends on the proportion
of people being tested in those
countries
however because of the surveillance
system we have here in the uk
because we test everybody who comes
through the border
we therefore do know where the risks are
and that's why we took the action we did
on pakistan and then on india as i say
before this was a a variant under
investigation
so yes it is absolutely right that we
have these tough border measures and
sometimes i get attacked
for having these tough border measures
and i don't regret them
at all but you have to take decisions
based on the evidence that you have
you can't take decisions based on
evidence that you don't yet have
and we took the precautionary decision
to put india on the red list based on
the
uh based on the epidemic that we saw
there
and then afterwards uh this this this
variant
was put under investigation of course
you can't take decisions based on trade
deals that you don't yet have either a
prime minister due to travel to india in
late april uh
to try and secure of course that
all-important post-brexit trade deal bit
tricky if hindu was on the red list
but i guess you're going to tell me that
had nothing to do with it at all
well we bet we take these decisions uh
based
on the evidence and we just had a
discussion of the epidemiology and
why we took the decisions when we did um
and and the fact actually that we took
the decision before we knew
uh about this as a this variant as a
variant
uh even under investigation and let
alone it then being notified as a
as a variant of concern okay and
very quickly is it right that you're
opening up vaccinations to
over 35s from tomorrow
um that is not quite right
but as you can see from the progress
that we've made
we are able to you know we are expanding
down through the age ranges pretty
rapidly you know i'm 42 and i was
vaccinated a couple of weeks ago
it's now open to 38 year olds and and
over
okay a little bit more time for me to
wait then hopefully not too much
not not to be selfish about these things
obviously um
just finally everybody everybody should
be enthusiastic
there's nothing wrong at all about being
enthusiastic about getting your jab
um i am also just of course the
restrictions
tomorrow some of them being lifted how
cautious should people be are you going
to be going around hugging people
yourself or are you going to be trying
to take a more cautious approach from
that than that
well i think we should all be careful we
all know the risks outside is safer than
inside so even though you can
from tomorrow meet up inside it's still
better to meet up outside
of course of course there's people who
have been yearning to have some physical
contact you should do that carefully
if you've had both jabs more than two
weeks ago that's much safer
so you know i was asked this on tuesday
and i said the thing i'm really looking
forward to is hugging my mum
she's had two jabs of course um actually
dad got quite upset about that i'm
really looking forward to hugging you as
well dad
and but you know we'll probably do it
outside and and
keep the ventilation going hands face in
space we all have a personal
responsibility
we all know now uh the sorts of things
that are
riskier but we're just we just you know
we're able
because the case numbers are so low to
move away from some of the more
um restrictive interventions and and
anyway
you know i think personal responsibility
is an important mantra here because
people have been so responsible through
the crisis
and they've really listened and followed
the uh the
the guidance and the instructions that
that the uh that the prime minister
set out and um and that's the approach
that we should take together
but it you know it's really it's really
it's really good that we can take this
step
uh and just finally just one more
question to you squeeze in it's about
the prime minister's holiday because the
daily mail
reported uh this weekend that the
parliamentary commissioner for standards
found
he hasn't been transparent about that
2019 caribbean holiday
it was worth more than twice the 15 000
pounds he declared it to be
the bill hadn't been met by the
conservative donor david ross as the
prime minister claimed
whether it's you know luxury holidays or
expensive wallpaper
why doesn't the prime minister just buy
things that he can pay for and
afford well
i think frankly there's so many more
important things
uh and i think that's what the voters
concluded at the uh elections a couple
of weeks ago
which is why we've spent which is really
talking about actually you talked about
one question on this but it is an
important question yeah and i'll tell
you
do you know what i'll tell you i'll tell
you what i really think sophie
when we were campaigning in those local
elections i knocked on one door in
middlesbrough
and this guy opened the door and without
me saying anything
he said you tell boris i don't care
about wallpaper
i care about the fact you've got me my
jab and that's the approach that i'm
taking
so journalists shouldn't ask politicians
about whether or not the prime
minister's broken rules
that doesn't matter you can ask me what
you like and now i'm going to talk to
you about
what i'm doing and covid and the prime
minister's followed the rules we all
know that
um and uh what matters for this country
is getting through and out of this
pandemic
and making sure that we can then have a
a great decade and the rest of the 2020s
it's brilliant it's been pretty
tough times i know there's endless
questions about this sort of thing
but i uh and i'm confident that the
rules
have been followed and what i do
is i concentrate on what's important for
the nation